okay newbies you're up five six ready
work
march those backs kitties am i doing
this wrong i feel like velma is
searching for her glasses
so you know how we're nowhere near the
places we thought we'd be in our lives
we spent the last part of our official
youth stuck inside just here watering
house plants
you have too many plants
i saw west today jewels i didn't see you
you were hiding behind a stack of
containers that are made out of clear
plastic are we actually seeing jewels
sexually frustrated i feel like i'm in
eighth grade well i can tell you what i
did in eighth grade and it involved
ruining several electric toothbrushes
very graphic
[Music]
my life is going nowhere nowhere
hiya kittens and here we go again where
are they all going they're all taking
flights to their future just like you
two have to do good luck figuring out
where you want to go dollface
today is the start of the new chapter
class i went to business school to
become an entrepreneur and we're putting
up a bar for women a bar with rosie on
tap somewhere where you can yell at the
tv while watching the bachelor i just
heard the words rose and bachelor in the
same sentence so yes to whatever that's
for
[Music]
i have decided to work hard and see
where it takes me i will mentor you yes
i have perfect skin and i'm wildly
successful but what is my legacy that
sounded pretty good
who was that he was clearly hitting on
you i thought my days of being attracted
to straight men were behind me and yet
here we are
you texted a guy without my input input
so what do we think of jules opening
here how did that make you all feel bad
ooh he might not remember my name let me
just no no no no
[Applause]
who thinks sending a gift just now was a
weird move
i need a drink pop that
that's how friends work
even if it's hard you trust each other
and you show up remind me again why you
needed us for this
if i had one what kind of do you think
i'd have
circumcised is it like shoes do you need
to walk around the store a little make
sure it's comfortable curve or no curve
these are the questions
[Music]
you